good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday oh my god it's thursday it's
friday eve we made it you guys to the
latter half of the week congratulations
pat yourselves on the back you did a
great job you really you're beautiful
stunning and smart we're working hard
we're getting [ __ ] done and we have
a new looking studio with some cool
chairs yeah so if you guys are watching
on youtube we buckled under the pressure
we were bullied
we were yikes
and now we have new chairs we are no
longer using our blue couch but the blue
couch will remain in the toast hall of
fame for its hard work its dedication
and honestly its courage because the way
people attacked that couch for its looks
like i thought we were beyond body
shaming and that blue couch with stood
the criticism never changed anything
about itself didn't
bow down to the mob didn't waver in who
it was
and that takes a really brave couch and
it's so important to remember that like
that couch was there for us when
literally nobody else was like we had no
other options so the way that like the
community just kind of descended on the
couch when the couch was literally
responsible for the youtube
it's upsetting but now we're in these
like gorgeous very trendy it's getting
like skinny confidential oh are they
trendy that's like the worst thing you
could say to me why like these these
chairs are so in yeah they're so in but
like trends to me connotes like a
fleeting trend oh but i just genuinely
liked these i got these for my house i
got them from scout in dallas they have
the coolest furniture and they arrived a
few days ago and then these two chairs
were just like sitting in my
i was in the middle of the hobby
[Laughter]
in my living room and honestly it looked
like a gorgeous set for the toe so i was
like
what if we've been those what if we just
brought those big heavy chairs upstairs
thank you zach shapiro and so this was
meant to be a temporary measure but i
actually think these are amazing
podcasting chairs because they're
comfortable you can lean back but
they're also structured they're also
wide which for me like i find extremely
valuable like i can sit on this chair
with thea we fit in the chair and that
means a lot to us so thank you yeah so i
think these chairs might be a permanent
fixture the rest of the set is still
gonna change and the design is gonna
change but um these are really premium
podcast chairs i don't know if scout had
that in mind when they designed them i
feel like they did you know podcasting
is the new frontier it is also from
no no blank is a new frontier yeah no
come on no it's not ugly betty it's like
one of those
it's a frontier it's a movie tracy term
blood i apologize for being so
uneducated yikes educate yourself
so
these chairs are called like i this is
how it's spelled but i don't know how
it's pronounced i someone made fun of me
already b-o-u-c-l-e
boucle oh i said buco
e how do you explain
i don't know it's just like a word
people know you know what i mean i never
saw before these are ivory booklet
chairs oh my god you're so okay so
literally
yeah
are you is this a new like your new
language what's your mother tongue
i speak my own language you speak stini
i speak stress
who doesn't
a lot of people and that's the problem
that's the problem um so i'm feeling
good you know premium audio premium
premium video hopefully yesterday was a
huge day for us um so it only took us
two
full days to get to like a tech free
tech issue free episode yesterday and
like when i tell you the mood that i was
in yesterday just like seeing all my
hard work come to fruition like i was so
happy and i'm just hoping for two days
in a row i don't think that's asking a
lot it's not but we did change the
formula so right no like we were [ __ ]
with the cameras with the lights with
everything so now i'm just nervous i
think it'll be great um sure
sure also i just wanted to shout out to
olivia ashrae um
olivia ashrae
i'm actually not olivia austria i'm sure
a lot of people thought i was because
i've been dressing like her because
you've been so private because
totally making my goodreads private
might be real private i'm literally like
so not like other influencers she's a
private celebrity she values her privacy
100
um but i've literally been waking up
every morning going to olivia's closet
and
acting like it was my own because i
didn't i knew i was coming here a
podcast and like hopefully vodcast but
it didn't like compute that i would need
outfits you know what i mean like i just
brought like sweatpants and bathing
suits so i'm dressing so much like
olivia austria and i feel like it's also
a mindset you know i love this blouse i
think you look great and i feel like
people have been loving your outfits
more than ever keeps asking for links
and it's not my stuff so i don't really
have links but just know whatever i'm
wearing if it belongs to olivia austria
it's most likely from boohoo um my shirt
is from boohoo and like we love a
thrifty queen you know where these pants
are from that i'm obsessed with that i'm
like trying to steal amazon why can't
you just get your own she said they're
discontinued she was gonna send me a
link but she couldn't find him so so i'm
screwed
you gotta steal him i gotta steal him i
know but i feel bad she like loves them
and she's doing me a favor by letting me
borrow them and pretend they're mine on
the podcast again hosting you and
feeding you and clothing so then i'm
going to steal like i borrowed a new
shirt of hers yesterday from sarah and
harry spit up on it like i'm literally
an animal well that's nobody's fault no
she would want that for her
she was so understanding whereas like if
i lent someone a new shirt i don't care
what the circumstances are like you're
kidding me you got my shirt dirty my new
shirt that i let you borrow where before
i've ever worn it's disgusting
even if it was harry
yeah no i would still be pissed not at
harry at the person i'm like it's your
responsibility yeah
but that's just a little bit about me
well you look great thank you so much
thank you it's funny now that i moved
and all my clothes are in different
places but also i can see all of my
clothes they're not just like hidden in
different corners and crevices or in
storage
i have a new outlook on my wardrobe and
like i'm seeing things i'm like why
don't i wear that oh these pants i used
to love these pants yeah but they used
to be so big on me and now they're snug
what if you just wore those pants what
if i just so i was finding out so i did
intrusive thoughts of one
bruno picked out my outfit he said mommy
you have to wear pink and purple that's
why you look pink and purple that's why
you look so stunning yeah i realized you
were styled by brew styled by bryson um
so we've got a great show it's thursday
which means nothing special you know
just means great stories great sisters
great fun we do have some pretty good
stories because i picked them out this
morning while i was pumping so i had
like a good chunk of 30 minutes to pick
them out i took my time i have some
interesting stories you know i like to
switch it up sometimes i like to do like
segments that feel more like
human interest
that but also like morning show type
segments where it's more of a
conversation and less of a news piece
you know i agree with you because
sometimes when we report and i love our
job like and it's perfect and everything
we do is literal perfection like you can
try to critique us but there would be
nothing for you to find um but sometimes
it's like okay someone got married cool
period what else like who like
like who cares you know yeah no i'm glad
you feel that way because i have a fifth
and final and it's always gonna be the f
it's always gonna be towards the end
worse it's just gonna i feel like make
us think
and make us realize things oh you know
what i got such an interesting dm right
before i started and i'm so glad i
remember because i wanted to bring it up
a conversation we were talking about
yesterday about the view and like their
potential replacements somebody dm'd me
that actually garcelle wrote in her book
how she
she like did a trial with them and she
said literally everyone was so [ __ ]
mean to her and she could never take
that job is that crazy no no it's not
but it's just a confirmation of what we
think yeah so i thought that was
interesting thank you to the toaster who
dm'd me that interesting fact toy that's
what you get for reading celebrity
memoirs you do get some factoids 100
mixed in there that are interesting um
so i'm so glad we are taking we're
literally the new directions like from
glee we're taking new direction with our
set with our stories we literally can't
stop evolving if we tried and we don't
stop believing much like the new
directions we've never stopped believing
do you know what the new directions are
of course
i know you're not like a die-hard gleek
i don't know if you you remembered like
the technical name of the glee club yeah
even though
hot take like that was the wrong name
for the glee club it doesn't stick you
know it's not like
you have to remind yourself that they
were called the new directions and it's
like oh that's kind of a weird name for
the glee club when there are so many
other iconic things about glee and the
fact that they were called the new
directions is not one of them what was
the name of their competitors the
warblers now that's an iconic name
that's an iconic name but the one that
adina menzel was the like choreographer
of and jesse st james was at
i don't know okay hold on it's like
important that i figured this out and
i'm sure if you're like a gleek
listening to the podcaster claudia do
better you're not a real gleek
jessie st james acapella group name it
was like the it was snazzy it was like
at carmel high school
vocal adrenaline like that's a good name
yeah the new directions is not snazzy
and i think it was the wrong name for
the glee club i think that's actually
not a hot take at all and then also why
i found found it problematic is because
first of all they really didn't take in
a new direction they did the same thing
every time and they're constantly being
compared to one direction and that's
just yeah a losing game
what was their high school called
willie mckinley william mckinley which i
do believe is an actual high school in
ohio
i need to think on better names for the
william mckinley glee club well actually
i thought the name of the high school oh
oh because i think the name of the high
school was actually really appropriate
it was because it really was just like a
ordinary public school that's middle
schools are called yeah like after
presidents
so um i could talk about glee all day
oh please don't
wow please don't we've got a glee hater
alert hater alert no not a hater i just
it's extremely we find ways to work glee
into every conversation so i don't need
like a dedicated conversation about it
that's so hurtful but i do understand
thank you look at the leaks
get her fine i'll come for you so
[ __ ] fast like you won't know what
hit you no it's actually really easy to
hate glee there's so much to hate i
don't hate glee i actually really like
it i'm saying like if you wanted to i i
would understand pretty much about it
looks like he's breastfeeding you oh
bryce he wishes i would let theo
breastfeed me but that doesn't say much
i think i'm gonna have to man spread in
order for brew to be comfortable oh my
god wow you're really sitting don't
cancel me you guys
because i'm man spreading did you just
mansplain to me what man's spreading is
i hate those words i was actually
thinking today about that
i was thinking today about that um
as i got ready i was thinking about like
the term body shaming okay like you just
called someone fat like we don't need a
whole new word for it i was thinking
about that about something recently i
forget one
i don't think this is what i was
thinking but i was also thinking about
the term like weaponizing like oh you're
weaponizing this against me it's like
you're just being mean yeah right right
right now we have new words forever
you're just like making fun of that i'm
not weaponizing it right like somebody
tweeted like somebody
messaged me or something yesterday and
it was like so based
i literally went to urban dictionary and
that just means this is cool no it's
like facts no lies were told oh cool
okay that's not overused to me but
and that's like why not say that doesn't
bother me a word like that where it's
just like a cool slang word what bothers
me is when we use these huge grandiose
words phrases menial things right and an
example of that and one of the most
overused words
this time of year century is gaslighting
someone says something like a little
nefarious gas lighting okay gaslighting
okay so i agree that like as a
generation we've taken that word way too
far people don't even know what it means
they just use it when someone's like
lying which is not what gaslighting is
but there are certain situations where
the the only way you can truly describe
what someone's doing to you adam oseri
is gaslighting like lying straight to
your face but making you think you're
the crazy yes of course no that's what
it means but now every single time
something ever happens i drop my pen on
the floor i'm gaslighting him no it's
true like or maybe i like made a mistake
i'm like the light was yellow no it was
red stop gaslighting me
and do you know who's the number one
perpetrator of that snatchler bensoffer
oh that's so funny because like maybe
like a year ago now i made the mistake
of saying gaslighting when me and ben
were arguing about something
and you won the argument obviously of
course but then i think he like liked
the word and and he literally he's like
did you walk theo i'm like yeah he's
like you're gaslight like he's so
obsessed with the word and honestly i
don't even think he knows like the true
meaning of it like most people who are
just using it as like someone lying yeah
like maybe i am lying but i'm still not
gaslighting you but the thing is like
you probably are
i think you're guessing me
it's literally like what came first the
chicken or the egg am i guessing you or
are you guessing me that's often how it
is in conversations because the other
person's like you're lying to make me
feel crazy like you're literally lying
you know and like we're just gaslighting
each other and that's why the whole
world is crazy toxic yeah
but i i do love to use gas lighting in
the perfect
situation for a perfect situation
because it's overused and it's lost its
power gas lighter denier
doing anything to get your ass farther
gaslight i love that song yeah that song
won't lose its power but the term has
lost it and you guys like that's why we
can't have nice words because they get
overused too true and we ruin them and
every single word in the english
language is overused at this point we
spoke about this like a while ago but
you probably don't remember it's a fresh
combo like
the fact that we you know you could say
something moderately funny and i'm
literally dead
it's true it's 100 so like dead doesn't
even mean anything enough oh
oh yeah of course and literally is also
one of those words oh yes you're not
literally dead you're like no i could
say i'm literally dead and i'm
completely alive do you want to see
someone doing well who's literally dead
knock wood you want to see someone who's
literally dead
you love playing dead i know like why as
kids did we all think being dead meant
your tongue hangs out of your mouth
like we all did that right
i think so oh we also did breaking bread
last night i forgot to talk about that
we actually had a really fun time
because we mostly just talked about
random [ __ ] like what we would order
from an ice cream truck yeah that was a
good combo yeah oh and disneychannel.com
and like the iconic games we used to
play cadet kelly sweet life so much fun
so much fun we also talked about
influencers on their periods
and my personal belief that if
i don't mind when influencers talk about
periods in general because like let's
talk about that and it's a part of life
crazy thing that happens to all of us
but if i know when you are on your
period and like
your cycle if i know your cycle you're
sharing too much and that's just like a
code i live by right
and that's not a statement on periods no
and if you want to talk about periods
where like the things that come along
sure yeah no but you're like there is a
point where period today right you
didn't need to know that yeah there's a
point where as like public figures like
you you can actually share too much and
i do believe the period should be the
line and i completely agree even though
i'm definitely guilty of sharing not
like letting people know i'm on my
period but just like usually when i'm
late i'm like like i like to guess like
the toasters into thinking i'm pregnant
that's different yeah
yeah is that gaslighting i don't think
so it's just like flip-flops
there's a huge difference between being
gaslighting and being annoying but
they're often mistaken for one another
yeah well everything's mistaken for
gaslighting look bruno is gasoliding me
right now because he won't sit with his
[ __ ] mommy yeah bruno sit your
[ __ ] ass down and don't work just sit
the [ __ ] down come to your mommy your
mommy loves you so much bruno
she's making so much space for you on
the chair like be grateful theo's
literally laying about to hang off the
chair
um okay well
do we have anything else we want to
catch up on before we dive in i don't
think so but you know things will come
up along the way as they do
how's your book going oh good so i'm
reading um hotel nantucket and as i said
previously ellen hildebrand is so
[ __ ] wordy
she is and she loves describing like
nantucket culture she's everything into
a restaurant with a full without a full
page of describing the lanterns the
beams and the way she describes food
especially in this book it's like the
sumptuous oysters brings her salsa the
salt of the brine reminds her of the
seashores that's
gone sit but the book is really good and
last night i had been reading for hours
i'm like let me just finish it before i
get to bed and then i checked i still
had an hour left
it's a long book it's so long but you're
reading it really quickly way faster
than that and i'm enjoying it by the way
it's a great beach reed
it's keeping me hooked i didn't feel
like it was like a really slow burn it
was interesting from the beginning
i like it i'm just like
ready for it to be over you know what
i'm saying yeah and that's no slight to
the book or ellen herself who's a queen
a queen i didn't get to read my book
because it's too spooky to read at night
and i didn't have any time to read it by
the way it is spooky and also um i
posted on my instagram that i was
reading in and my friend stacey is in
nantucket and she was like oh my god
this woman was at the bookstore today
signing books i didn't know like it was
like she was popular i'm like she's
literally like the biggest author ever
yeah and she's just chilling in that
tucker signing books but she lives there
yeah full time and it makes sense that
she would like do a signing during the
summer love that for her yeah
so i guess now without further ado to do
where are you
you're being annoying on the floor
it's time for the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast or
as bruno says
i just had a [ __ ] heart attack oh my
god what's going on today today's
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life well that's how our brains
work so why don't we treat them that way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain like learning a
new language or taking power naps and
there's also better help better help is
an online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see a
camera anyone on camera if you don't
want to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
better help is so accessible it's so
easy to use and there's really no reason
why you shouldn't be
utilizing it it's they make it super
affordable if you don't like or you
don't connect with your initial
therapist you can change it's super easy
um
and you don't have to leave your house
which is even more important and you can
text you can video chat you can do all
the things and our listeners are getting
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
toast that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash toast today's episode is also
brought to you by missouri
there are moments in life that aren't
typically celebrated
most people think about buying jewelry
for occasions only but missouri does
find jewelry differently by celebrating
every day not just the big moments their
pieces are high quality and they are
designed for you to wear your way
whatever your taste is whatever your
mood is and whatever your budget is
missouri drops new limited edition
products every monday they feature
responsibly sourced diamonds recycled
14-karat solid gold pieces so you can
sweat in them shower in them and sleep
in them that's the best like wearing a
lot of necklaces during the day and then
having to take them off one by one to
get in the shower so your neck like
doesn't turn green is so annoying and
missouri's the best because i find that
they're extremely reasonably priced and
you can shower with all of their
products they're also just like really
in style very classic you know dainty
ones
rings necklaces i learned about them
classy i learned about them from lauren
elizabeth she used to have a collab with
them and it was just like so dainty and
she's a classy gal right i have a
necklace from there that's an h i've
been wearing them a lot and it's so cute
and sweet you can discover fairly priced
and expertly handcrafted styles to wear
and love forever so if you're looking
for a sign to buy yourself the diamond
or gold hoops the bracelets or the
necklaces then this is it make your own
day at missouri.com that's m e j u r i
dot com missouri.com
great thank you it's pleasure our first
story sydney sweeney is talking to the
hollywood reporter and sharing some tea
about her earnings she says i barely
earn enough to survive oh please
euphoria star cindy sweeney revealed her
while it does not yet justify a break to
enjoy the lush life she said if i wanted
to take a six-month break i don't have
income to cover that i don't have
someone supporting me i don't have
anyone i can turn to to pay my bills or
call for help she said she doesn't
profit as much from her day job as
people might think she said they don't
pay actors like they used to and with
streamers you no longer get residuals
she also said the established stars
still get paid but i have to get five
percent to my lawyer 10 to my agents
three percent or something like that to
my business manager i have to pay my
publicist every month and that's more
than my mortgage if i just acted i
wouldn't be able to afford my life in la
i take deals like sponsorships of course
because i have to yeah of course she's
the face of tory burch she was um i
think also the face of a new lineage
campaign yes she works with lineage
armani beauty mew mew tory burch i'm
sorry i have like a really hard time
believing this like first by the way and
i agree with what she's saying like and
this is something we talk about a lot
how like being a celebrity people
definitely think you make more money
than you do until you're at a certain
level and you pay you like
pay so many other people's salary like a
lawyer a manager a business manager an
agent a publicist all these things so
there's definitely
you know
a misconception but i don't believe that
she couldn't take six months off like if
she wanted to well and not keep living
her life at the level that she's looking
at right now but
why does sydney sweeney i know that she
like does need a publicist but like what
if cindy sweeney just didn't have a
publicist like she would still get
publicity yeah no i think at her level
it's not about getting publicity but
it's like when you do get public
publicity making sure you're protected
like you going to an interview feeling
safe that the interviewer is not going
to like attack you you going on a red
carpet making sure like everything is
organized for you yeah at that point
it's not about getting press it's about
managing the press got it but some
people hire publicists like
lower level celebrities who actually
need prep pitch them get them invited to
events
like hollywood reporter wants to talk to
sydney regardless of her publicist but
her publicist will arrange all of this
schedule the car do everything and make
sure that hollywood reporters briefed on
everything sydney's got going on yeah
okay fine fair
it's just interesting no it is
interesting and she's definitely like
still technically new on the scene i
would say she really only blew up in the
last like year and a half yeah and i
doubt this she'll be in this position
for very much longer no because she's
really like the next big thing yeah but
she also is
only doing tv like i don't think she's
done any movies she's known for euphoria
and white lotus
so you definitely can make a lot of
money on tv but in neither of those
shows is she the main character so
actually like actually i kind of believe
this yeah but i think big things are
coming for her right it's also just a
misconception when she shows up on the
red carpet full glam in a ten thousand
dollar dress that she's gonna get back
yeah so people just assume things about
her
um
and i'm just
i love sydney sweeney she's also not
like other girls like actually though
how so she's like obsessed with cars she
doesn't even have a tick tock she has a
tick tock for her like
garage like her mechanics garage yeah i
did see she's a mechanic she's like
every guy like is obsessed with her
because she is like perfect looking and
also like loves cars like what are the
odds like stop
like seriously stop it's not fair what
am i gonna have to do to get attention
like literally buy like a pickup truck
and start fixing it up yeah she's
raising the bar and she has to stop yeah
it's too high it's too high like stop it
it was already like threatening with the
way that she looks but she can't help
that she can help getting like into cars
as a hobby it's actually disrespectful
to the females
as a as a
gender
i completely agree so she's on my list
anyways i thought that was interesting
like yeah it takes a while to be making
those big bucks and even someone who is
pretty a-list like her that reminds me
of when the pretty little liars girl no
fifth harmony said the same thing when
they were like at the peak of fifth
harmony they were like we're really not
even making that much money okay but
that actually makes sense to me in music
like music is so [ __ ] up and it's
years for you to get uh royalties from
your songs and the way that the music
industry is structured with like
streaming like spotify and then also
record labels is like you're really
being taken advantage of
when you get paid and then you also then
have to pay your manager your agent your
publicist your business manager like and
then split it into five right and that's
why so many people who do music like do
other things like cardi b is literally
like one of the top creators on only
fans and i bet she makes literally just
as much money for music as she does from
only fans well once your songs are at
the level of cardi b you make a lot of
money but you make more money though
from like the tour and the merch and
sponsorships and commercials and brand
deals and she has her own company now
like that vodka whipped cream that
people love so you have to be doing like
a million things when your main gig is
music unless you're at the level of like
taylor swift
bono
beyonce coldplay yeah i feel like that's
the
i don't know maybe i wouldn't include
bono in there but at one point that was
nice that you did you were thinking
about i was just trying to cast a wide
net you know
yeah but you know what i do find
interesting is like when i compare like
sydney sweeney's rise it reminds me just
a little bit in terms of the timing is
like addison ray and i feel like addison
ray probably makes like triple maybe
more of what sydney sweeney makes and
that's just on social media yeah addison
wright is also like a commercial girl
like cindy sweetie is an artist and art
doesn't pay it's true until you uh you
are like the point zero zero one percent
of successful artist and that's one
thing about me like i'm going to be a
commercial girly i'm not gonna be an
artist like i need money
yeah but like
i'm not going to be too proud to like be
an artist then also start five companies
like kind of how addison loves to act so
that's not even you being anti-art it's
you being pro-mogul energy right like
addison i think she would say her artist
like dancing and acting
but her money comes from item beauty
from social media from doing brands and
like
she's not gonna stop doing that and i
think if addison wanted to take a
six-month break and it feels like she's
been on one so yeah she can survive 100
right no no nobody's disagreeing with
you and she has been on a break and
that's also why so many um like actors
or musicians become like
kind of influencers
like becoming like creating a lot of
content starting youtube channels doing
brand deals like shane mitchell she's a
perfect example
yeah well it's also just a good career
plan and a backup plan it also makes you
more valuable when you go into an
audition yeah it's like the show is
about the show on her youtube right
that's free press right
so i never hire a publicist anyone who
like gets you know like weird about like
social media because they love their art
like you're gonna have to evolve like
you gotta evolve you're gonna get lower
you can just be an artist right and then
you can take a six-month break about it
right i guess right
are you ready for our next story i am
ashton kutcher is explaining why he's
returning further that 70 show spin-off
called that 90 show did you know that
there is a that's 70 show spin-off
coming out no i had no idea but we
literally spoke about like spin-off and
reboot culture on breaking bread last
night like whether or not
you know as a society we've like had
enough of these reboot reunion things i
agree but this one sounds promising okay
well for you to say that yes i like the
premise because it's a little bit of a
reunion and a little bit of a reboot
okay so the premise it's called that 90
show it's set in 1995 and it follows
tougher grace's topher yeah him you and
the pronunciations i well you know what
i read once people who mispronounce
things only learned about them from
reading so don't make fun of them oh i
thought you were going to say like
people who misremember pronounce things
are like highly intelligent people are
always attributing like bad qualities to
high intelligence you know that's not
what i was gonna say but like i only
learn
how to say it from reading it right and
like you're gonna really knock me for
reading and you know they do say
actually people with poor memories like
me is a sign of high um intellectuality
really where did you hear that it's a
common knowledge actually everyone knows
that
i've seen it like a lot of places like a
lot of memes it must be true
okay anyways that 90s show is following
topher grace and laura prepon's daughter
okay because i guess there are a couple
in the show yeah her name is leia
foreman and she's visiting her
grandparents for the summer who are kurt
wood smith and deborah joe rupp who are
the parents in that section yeah so it's
like the next generation and the former
generation and the former generation
it's kind of like girl meets world how
yeah that guy corey
what's the dad's name in girl meets
world korean topanga corey yeah it's
cory's in it but it's about sabrina
carpenter and rowan blanchard and
this is about
eric and donna's daughter and she's
visiting her grandparents for the summer
who are the parents in that 70s show and
they're replaying red and kitty and they
will also follow a new generation of the
point place kids while some of the older
characters stop in for a visit wait
speaking of sabrina carpenter did you
see last night was the premier red
carpet for high school musical the
musical the series season three yes and
joshua bassett and olivia rodrigo like
post together smiling together posted on
social media together yeah which is
crazy and to be honest like
they're gaslighting i was like no and
it's like
joshua bassett this girl like
literally annihilated who dragged you
i was actually have you know scribbles
when i was at the sink this morning i
had that song in my head deja vu
and i was just thinking about the lyrics
maybe because i saw those pictures
when you gonna tell
her like it's all about like blowing up
his spot that all the things that he's
doing with his new girl like not new not
fresh do you have deja vu and it's like
where are his scruples posing with her
it's i'm not even it used to be like she
was mad at him because he dumbed her but
then like she got her revenge in the
biggest baddest way right like she she
can't even be mad at him he can be mad
at her
right and a lot of people are talking
about sabrina carpenter's new album
which is apparently extremely raw and
real it's called emails i can't send or
something i haven't listened to it but
it's like blowing up on tick tock and
i'm happy for her like she deserves it
there was also some drama
what something with julian michael yes
yes i follow everything loosely from a
glance because i follow sabrina right so
then i get some like targeted sabrina
stan julia michaels like had to
deactivate her twitter because she was
like fighting with a sabrina carpenter
fan
who i think the sabrina carpenter when
that happened
like you think you held a grudge listen
to this
this sabrina carpenter fan i think once
had tweeted like she hates every song
julia michaels writes
then the serenity harbinger fan was like
oh man this album's so good i love it
and then she's responding to this fan
account like but i thought you hate
every song i write and i've literally
written every song on this album and
then she deactivated her twitter it's
like first of all why are you fighting
with a fan second of all why are you
blowing up sabrina carpenter's spot like
that you literally like are responsible
for this album yeah no it's like you're
on you're in the credits
it was weird behavior honestly like for
a public figure who should know better
yeah and also she's an artist in her own
right like
it's just weird it's artistry once again
yeah
sorry i took a debrief but i just wanted
to say those pictures of olivia rodrigo
and joshua batson like she looked so
beautiful yeah i just couldn't find a
scruple yeah
i was looking in the picture mike i said
in the background no scribbles from
joshua bassett
and also i just couldn't help but wonder
if it was you know forced on them to do
that like press-wise because like they
[ __ ] around too much like i think
after season one everyone was obsessed
and then like when they hated each other
so much like it kind of fell off at
least from like
me i think the teeny boppers still watch
it but like i was literally a 27 year
old woman watching high school musical
the musical the series on disney plus
and i just want to say i'd like not to
be that girl but i actually watched high
school musical the musical series before
the hype before the drama wow like i
just really liked the art
wow you're literally trendsetter
not like other trendsetters no not at
all and i just want to say as far as
like forcing them to take this picture
for the hype i don't think anyone
especially like the high school musical
the musical the series team can force
olivia rodrigo to do anything at this
point honestly they should be like
grateful that she even came well so i
know that like she has a contract and
she probably had to show up but the fact
that she still does this little like
instagram show is so crazy to me like
literally the biggest pop star in the
world and she's still like acting on the
show that got her started it's nice and
i would like to think it was like a
choice of hers but i don't believe she
had a choice i think it's good i think
it's good that she's still doing it i
think it's a good sign because obviously
she's not a one-hit wonder and she'll be
around for a really long time but it is
always good to like maintain
the things that built you up the
building blocks instead of just like
shooting off into the stratosphere i
agree completely and even though
she shot off into the stratosphere like
still laying that foundation agreed
brick by brick no she's gonna be huge
she is but she definitely has staying
power she has yeah but when you have
that meteoric rise there's always the
worry that you don't and i think by her
doing all these things still and not
just
only riding the wave yes it's more
contributing to like her longevity yeah
i agree it's more grounded agreed
are you ready for our next story oh so
what do you think about that 90 show
reboot idea
it's just like hard for me to care i was
never like that 70s show girl and the
only time i've ever watched it is like
when it's been on nick at night like
when i was looking for the nanny um
and honestly i just found laura prepon's
character unbelievably annoying and i
like that it's like the starting place
of like ashton and mila it's like an
important
you know fixture and pop culture but as
a tv show i didn't give a [ __ ] like at
all yeah no i agree with that also the
story was that ashton kutcher is talking
about like why he's coming back because
i'm sure people would be like it's like
mary kay naturally going a full house it
would never happen but because him and
mila met there um
he said it was really nostalgic to be
back on the set it's all the same folks
that made that 70s show so it was pretty
bizarre but they felt like returning was
the right thing to do mila and i were
contemplating it we thought listen we're
only in the position that we're in
because of that show so let's just go
back and do this we just went back and
had fun for a week it was so random and
fun i love ashton and mila like i think
they're like actual people even though i
think they said they're like don't give
their kids baths or maybe that was
kristen bell um
so i like this it's just like not
everyday and like not with soap
but the one thing i wanted to say is
like the problem with like reunion
reboot spin-off culture is that more
often than not when a show gets really
popular back in the day like there's one
person who like becomes more famous than
the rest of them so when it comes time
for a reboot all these like loser
husbands are like sure where do i sign
up
and like the one person who everyone
wants to see zac efron won't show up
yeah you know yeah so that's a problem
in my opinion but this is good because
it sounds like all the stars like wilmer
valderrama is gonna be in it right and i
think the reason why this will be
successful is yes that and that's
because ash and mila i think are actual
like human beings not like celebrity
zombies i think they're like a unique
breed of a-list where they're like nice
yeah but isn't there that one guy from
that 70s show who's like in jail oh
right thank you danny masterson yeah he
was convicted on some crazy sexual
assault charges i think he actually
might be in prison yeah so i'm sure he
won't show up but it's nice that they
didn't let like him you know ruin the
derail all the like
it's no it's nice because so many people
love the show i don't but like it had
the potential to like stay in the whole
franchise yeah and they're moving past i
also think this show has potential
because if like they nail the 90s i
think a lot of new viewers might be into
it and because nostalgia for the 90s
just like those people wanted nostalgia
for the 70s no and but also like gen z
who wasn't even alive in the 90s they're
obsessed with y2k 90s culture so like
it's kind of on point yeah love that for
them
no one else i love
our next sponsor
next evo if you ever ever wondered
whether your cbd was working that means
it probably wasn't nextevo naturals
developed smartsword technology
clinically proven to help your body
absorb cbd four times fast better than
regular cbd oil because oil just doesn't
mix with your water-based body it also
works faster when you feel stress coming
on you won't waste time wondering is it
working next evo isn't just another cbd
company they're all natural products are
backed by more scientific studies than
any other cbd brand they've they're
developed by experienced consumer
healthcare and pharmaceutical
professionals they're vegan gmo free
gluten free and thc free capsules and
gummies that are derived from 100 u.s
grown hemp i am a cbd girly i'm very
particular i really like gummies um
and i've tried a bunch of different
brands and i happen to really really
like next evo mostly because like i can
actually feel the effects and sometimes
in the past i've felt like it's almost
like a placebo i'm like is this working
um so you can stop wondering if cbd is
right for you and try next evo naturals
capsules gummies mints and topical
creams clinically proven to be better by
absorbing your body
get 25 off your first order of 40 or
more at nextevo.com with the promo code
toast so it's 25 off at n-e-x-t
evo.com promo code toast
okay our next story
anna de armas is stunning as marilyn
monroe in behind-the-scenes photos from
new movie a biopic about marilyn called
blonde so anna posted a glimpse of her
transformation on instagram on wednesday
and i want your thoughts on these photos
and anna as marilyn okay
so here she is with adrienne brody he is
my god i love adrian brody yeah jewish
king wait let me see when and scroll
through all the photos because there's a
lot of different um
she dead ass looks like marilyn monroe
there's a lot of photos from the set
that have emerged
oh my god that really looks like her
which one is that marilyn monroe or is
that that's anna she looks great by the
way anna armas is beautiful it's like a
high production the makeup the
prosthetics everything's going to be
incredible i'm just like a little
underwhelmed i can't really explain why
you know what i think it is
honestly like
anna jarmus doesn't do it for me she
does it for me yet these photos don't no
it this doesn't feel like a natural role
and you know i actually saw tick tock of
someone you know doing their dream cast
for evelyn hugo and anna darmus as
evelyn hugo and for me that felt like
right
um that does feel right yeah but i don't
know why because i think evelyn is
younger
is she's latin right yes so i just felt
like that was a great fit like when when
you know a character and then the person
who's gonna play them like you have to
feel like they're connected and honestly
i feel like anna darmis is like a little
new
to be i don't know it's just playing
such an icon yeah so like these are the
photos that came out yesterday and it's
just to me and i think with a lot of
these like biopics and just based on
real people and real stories it's a
little too cosplay
and i also feel like if it was someone
whose face we didn't know very well we
could have an easier time imagining a
mad like morphing them into but it just
looks like she's dressed up as marilyn
for halloween in some of the more iconic
photos like the white dress and the pink
you know diamonds are a girl's best
friend in general by the way
but when it's like she's on this
windowsill with bonnie bobby cannavale
as joe dimaggio i love bobby cannavale
or however he says yeah me too for this
role i think he's an amazing actor and
honestly like him and rose byrne as a
couple is the cutest thing of all time
the cutest thing of all time yeah i
don't know something about this is just
like underwhelming in the sense that um
like i don't care you know oh no i care
and i would love a biopic on maryland
because like everybody knows her but
like who's the real marilyn i don't know
i'm not a maryland expert who did um who
played maryland in my week with marilyn
one of those girls which one with
michelle
oh she wouldn't do it for me either
honestly i feel like it should be an
unknown michelle williams that's what's
tough about these biopics and like why i
think austin butler was a great choice
for elvis because honestly unless you're
watching zoey 101 like you have no idea
who this man is um but when you're such
a star
it's distracting and that's what
boslerman said why he wouldn't cast
harry styles as elvis like it would not
be a movie about elvis it would be a
movie about harry styles as elvis yeah
it's really hard to nail these things
and i'm trying to think of someone who
did and you know what it reminds me of
joaquin phoenix and walk the line
perfection and i feel like even though
we weren't like johnny cash stands we
liked it but i think even the johnny
cash stands liked his portrayal and i
think i mean that was joaquin phoenix's
breakout role he wasn't super known
before that his brother was yeah so
that made sense and that's why it was
just and same with reese witherspoon she
was like legally blonde but she wasn't
like
that wasn't really her first more
serious role right so it was perfect on
all fronts yeah so these things are
really tough to cast i feel like
recently all of the movies that i've
seen that are based on real people it's
like giving this
cosplay halloween vibe it's like
yeah um inventing anna i didn't watch
that it had that element okay i was
gonna say house of gucci like lady gaga
was
halloween
and
the eyes of tammy fay i'm sorry i
[ __ ] love that movie i liked it but
it's just like i was watching someone in
costume playing a different person like
yes but the difference
the difference is that that's what tammy
thing looked like in real life like she
was this
outrageous like makeup hair like
southern that's really what she was like
i was just watching jessica chastain's
prosthetics i thought jessica i loved
that movie i liked it and i liked the
story and i liked it like i liked it but
it was just so costumey yeah i think
andrew garfield was that great in it no
he doesn't do it for me me neither and
like that's a really hot take like there
are women who would literally stand in
traffic just to like
be in the same room as andrew garfield
and i'm just not one of those girls
okay and that's just a little bit not
everyone can be or else everyone's
standing in traffic right and that's
what makes me not like other girls yeah
and that would cause more traffic a
ruckus
okay ready for our next story i am lamar
odom is coming out of the woodworks to
say that khloe kardashian could have
hollered at me for another baby
he has to stop like for real he's not
done shooting his shot with chloe in an
exclusive video obtained by page six the
former la lakers star reacted to the
news that his ex-wife is expecting her
second child via surrogate he told a
reporter that he would gladly have
helped her expand her family over her
cheating ex had she asked he said quote
she could have hollered at me for that
um
not that i want to like give this any
like legs but don't we know that um
chloe and lamar were like incompatible
in terms of fertility because they had
tried when they were together so that
doesn't really help yeah no they tried
when they were together and they
couldn't so so thanks but thanks for the
empty offer
meaningless yeah that's like me saying
like yeah um
if you need a billion dollars i'll give
it to you i don't have a billion dollars
you know yeah no i would you already
have a billion dollars but you're saying
i would have given it to you it's like
no one's yeah right because not only do
i not have it but you already have you
don't need it thanks
um and i do love lamar and i do feel
like his sentiments towards chloe like i
have respect for them like he knows he
messed up he knows he would like he
would probably be dead without her like
he knows all this stuff so i really love
that he acknowledges that but like
now it's at a point where he talks about
her so frequently and anytime he's in
the news it's about chloe that like
it's getting thirsty and that's just
something i never saw for lamar
especially after his accident you know
yeah like when he was on celebrity big
brother like every time they would write
about what he was doing in the show he
was like talking to someone about chloe
yeah and honestly chloe feels about it
i think she probably feels really sad
yeah like that was such a bad time in
her life between like their divorce and
then his overdose like i'm sure she and
then like the way she just like did
everything for him like they gave him a
house right when he was recovering they
i think they like did everything so i'm
sure she like
it's triggering honestly for her to
that's like another one of those words
you know yep like overused new image
word where it's like overused but i
think this is like i think this actually
yes no but it's used to just mean i'm
bothered
yeah triggered or i don't feel amazing
triggered triggered yeah um but i do
think this is actually like a case of
triggering because i think that entire
time of her life was so horrible and it
feels like one of those situations where
it's like another lifetime yeah you know
but she keeps getting pulled into it
because it's literally like ever it's
quarterly that he's in the news talking
about her yeah and typically even like
i'm sure a lot of people have exes who
feel like another lifetime ago but then
like you don't have to hear what they
think about your new life right in front
of the world right
so it's just like another case of
justice for chloe um
and we're just used to it at this point
you know yeah as the judges and justice
first chloe i wonder how shaq feels
about it right i hope he's feeling
protective of his new new woman
[Laughter]
you know what we could do because we
don't actually we don't know these
people like we're never going to see
them we're never going to like invite
them over for dinner and they don't
bring speak for yourself and they don't
bring shaq it's like what if we just
live in a world
in like a fantasy world where chloe and
jack are together let's move forward as
such and we could do that with a lot of
people yeah like
let me get me and john mayer right no
but we know you and we know that and
then i met you for dinner when it's been
here where's john
one could say that like ben looks like
john in a dream world
he does
actually people have told me that a lot
of times okay yeah
um
like
what's the word when you
fantasize yeah like i guess like fan
fiction about our favorite celebrities
right
and just
pretend
what if you just pretended
but then i feel like that's a really
slippery slope towards like mental
illness where we're just like living
in multiple
universes and realities and not in
reality and like i know myself i know my
mental health like i know i'm extremely
susceptible to like some sort of
psychotic break and you might be the one
to push me there okay fake universe so
it's a bad idea yeah i'm gonna say no
actually okay but thank you for
entertaining and i appreciate that it's
a pleasure
unfortunately we have to live in reality
you guys damn i've tried but
honestly
i don't want to live in reality but i
really don't want to be known as one of
those people who like lives with
rose-colored glasses and like is
unrealistic because i [ __ ] hate those
people and i have too much
self-awareness to ever be that girl you
know yeah like a delusional queen
i think a healthy dose of delusion is
good yeah like hoping chloe in check
running into each other having faith in
yourself like yeah maybe even to a point
of like a little delusion but it's a
slippery slope because then you become
one of those people who like
literally is like always lying you know
yeah and i never want to be that person
so if i ever am just like kill me i'll
let you know thanks
are you ready for our fifth and final
story the final story
let's live in reality
yeah
it's a good place to live
sometimes
our fifth and final story which i'm
assuming is thought provoking and
conversation starting yep is brought to
you by stamps.com uh also thought
provoking and conversation starting when
you're running a small business every
second counts and you can't afford to
waste a single moment so why are you
still taking time out of your day to go
to the post office when you could be
using stamps.com instead stamps.com
makes running nope stamps.com makes
mailing and shipping quick easy and cost
effective for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been an indispensable
service for over 1 million businesses
they give you access to all the post
office and ups shipping services that
you need right from your computer and
you can get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to 30 off usps
rates and 86 off ups they streamline
your shipping process with stamps.com
easy to use software so whether you're
running a side business a small business
from shopify amazon etsy ebay anything
you can uh seamlessly work with their
software sending invoices sending out
your products warehouse shipping out
your orders they will do everything they
are mailing and shipping solution so
stop wasting time and start saving money
when you use stamps.com
sign up with promo code toast for a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and enter code toast
great thank you our fifth and final
story is gonna make you think a little
bit and i feel like it's gonna make
everyone just realize like where they
are and who they are so important to be
realizing things constantly that's what
i learned from um guru kylie
here are a list of celebrities who are
turning 30 in 2022. oh okay that's
interesting it is interesting when you
like think about how you remember them
right and also a lot of celebrities i
feel like when i learn to learn how old
they are it blows my mind because
they're either like way younger than i
thought or way older yeah okay that
happens all the time so one suki
waterhouse that feels right okay sean
johnson
wow really
i would have thought she was older just
because the olympics feel so long ago
but she was so young yeah avengea from
victorious there's a lot of like our
disney channel nickelodeon stars the way
i would have taken a bullet for evan
jogia when i was like 16. no sorry like
12
exposing myself um was real like i was
obsessed
taylor lautner
king
emily osmond
lily yeah that trap all that whole crew
is turning 30 this year miley celina
nick jonas
musical the musical the series do you
know who's in this season
i saw him on the red carpet like in the
cast photo i was shook
jason earls
jackson from hannah montana wow i'm so
glad disney's reaching out to him and
getting him involved in more shows
because
he deserves it yeah um and that was just
really like joyous for me i was very
excited
vanessa morgan from riverdale okay sam
smith greg sulkin
jeanette sam smith greg sulkin okay so
far nobody has shocked me jeanette
mccurdy tracks celina we knew yeah carly
kloss would have thought she was older
i don't know why because she's like a
grown-ass woman yeah
we've always known her as tall no she's
tall she's been around for a thousand
years i literally would have guessed she
was 37 dead ass yeah the sprouse bros we
know that because we've been following
them but i feel like for people who only
know them from sweet life that's a
shocker i know them because we both we
went to nyu together at the same time
and i used to see them around campus so
they couldn't have been that much older
or younger than me yeah cara delevingne
she's 45. yeah i'm joke uh demi lovato
fair because she's in that
circle of the send it on the send all
the sended on kids are turning through
turning 30. kim petras
oh wow
i would have thought she was like
literally 21. yeah i love kim petras
i've been telling mario about kingpetras
for years because brian introduced me to
her like right when i met brian and now
i've known ryan for what four years so
four years ago margo doesn't listen to
me and then on her instagram the other
day she's like i can't we've been
sleeping on kim petras i'm like [ __ ] i
literally told you i literally tried to
wake her up a thousand times she snoozed
you don't know why she why she's into it
now because there was a kim petra song
in the summer i turned pretty and so
marcus has been listening to the
soundtrack and it was such a good
competitor song i mean if you're
sleeping on kim petrus like
what are you doing wake up i'm
embarrassed for you
wake up also i listened to snatcher
songs this morning as i got ready the
playlist it's so pleasant she's so
trendy and she's she's such a
trendsetter taste maker yeah gas slider
next up nick jonas which we know trucks
chase stokes which is interesting
considering he's like more new on the
scene and he's playing in 18 he's paying
a 12 year old yeah cardi b
this is always a shocking one cardi b is
one of the celebrities that when i found
out how old she was her and adele i
think are the same age no no no sorry no
um
when i found out how old she was i was
shocked i think it said adele and taylor
swift are the same yes they're both 32.
what was the name of adele's album 30
hello no because she does it always in
the year 30 was that what it was yeah i
think so
so maybe she's 31 now
josh hutcherson from
peta
no gail
no peta
no gail liam hemsworth that's confusing
because it's a girl's name
21 savage cool odell beckham jr oh
nathan cress who's freddy from icarly
trucks
miley trucks jyn from bts that's
surprising that one of the bts man
members is 30. yeah because maybe it's
only maybe it's because their fans are
like 12. yeah so i would have assumed
they were also like 16 you know yeah
tory kelly
that makes sense i've been like
inundated with the tory kelly content
because every time i get home from the
toast singh is on in the shapiro
household and she plays the elephant
which makes no sense um
and she's so talented me and olivia were
talking about it like why isn't she more
famous
i just people aren't gravitated towards
her like no she's so talented and she
has all of the press and all of them
she's with scooter braun yeah she's
everything but some people just don't
take off don't yeah and you know who
that also reminds me of is madison beer
yeah and so they're like i feel like
with like when you're a part of scooter
bronze crew like nine times out of ten
like you're gonna become a mega mega
star but like there's a few outliers and
tory kelly is one of them madison beer
is one of them and they remind me so
much of each other just in terms of the
trajectory of their career where there
was so much hype in the beginning
and
then scooter brawn and then like nothing
yeah but it's not for lack of trying and
not for lack of like resources or all of
those things it's just like
people
weren't
like
diving like
for tory kelly i feel like that's the
case for madison beer i feel like people
were vibing in the industry was not yes
but now
people are vibing the industry's still
not
i don't know
like everything she does like i feel so
like janky for tori kelly the people
aren't vibing but the industry is like
she gets you she performs at the grammys
she was on that dan and jae song she um
is in sing like she gets all these
opportunities and most people don't even
know who she is and then with madison
everybody knows her and it's like she's
i like her with madison beer like yeah
tori kelly gives like industry plant
vibes whereas madison beer like has so
many fans so many followers a lot of her
music has been like going viral on tick
tock but there's no like mainstream
energy there's no pickup
and then she like went back on tour she
released an album people on like gen z
teenagers were obsessed with it she went
on tour and like she was playing these
like janky small theaters it just was
weird yeah they should
become a duo yes and then they would be
they would hit the stratosphere it does
feel like somebody blackballed madison
beer out of the music industry but she's
still trying her best yeah i wonder who
it was um bridget mendler is also
turning 30. that makes me feel old jade
from little mix
oh that makes sense and jackie ashrae is
turning 30 this year oh my god you are
these are like my age people and you
know what this makes me feel good like
that these are my contemporaries
contemporaries i'm like to me they don't
seem old and they don't seem young
and that's my age group and i'm okay
with that they're all like a lot of
those people not all a lot are at the
top of their game they're just getting
started oh yeah and a lot of them are
also married with kids having kids like
no i honestly if i were you i wouldn't
have any qualms about turning 30. like
you have a child a husband a house a
successful business like the only real
scary part of getting older is when you
feel like you're not where you should be
yeah but i feel like you're really on
track don't feel worried about it no i
didn't feel worried and i just thought
it was interesting the other celebrities
who are also turning 30. so sophia with
enough just turned 30. yes i saw that on
instagram i can't believe she was left
off the list
obviously people magazine is slacking
slacking
um so with the two did you think about
the story would you want something like
that again sometime in the future i
definitely would like i would actually
think maybe we should like make an
official change like the fifth story
unless there's crazy [ __ ] news which
there never is five stories i think the
fifth story should be reserved for more
like broad like what we did yesterday
with the girls from new zealand and i
apologize to everyone listening like our
millions of fans in australia and new
zealand i mixed up the two because to me
they're like so similar but they're not
so i'm sorry
um
i like [ __ ] like that like human
interest you know i'm gonna keep that in
mind yeah i think like people magazine
is really good for that yeah then you
always have like you know morbidly obese
man locked in a cabinet for six years
emerges and he um
something you know now that i'm
following the new york post on instagram
there's a lot of stories like that so i
will flag them for the fifth story
fabulous um and that was our show we
hope everyone enjoyed the new set we
hope all the audio was premium for
everyone listening as a podcast we do we
do and we've got one more show of the
week and i'm like i'm rdh because we
keep getting like better and better
every episode and then once friday it's
like there's no show saturday you know
i'm just feeling like
but maybe monday like we'll have like so
many days of
things to talk about for sure yeah oh
and also like we maybe could go to home
goods maybe there'll be a potted plant
on the table oh yeah we're gonna
definitely spruce it up think think some
things through i have one thing coming
that isn't meant for this setup but like
maybe it could be we'll discuss we'll
discuss
and
it's not friday so we'll see you guys
tomorrow and why are we acting so final
i don't know thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast okay get
your hopes up where are we going stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube like
we have spent we hit 90k so why don't
you
recognize where you at grateful
i just want to say like the amount of
time
money energy sweat we have put into this
studio is all for you so if you could
just do us a solid of like just clicking
like click you need to refocus your
efforts because everybody i think who
watches on youtube subscribes because we
have more subscribers than daily viewers
yeah so
talk to the podcasters appeal to them as
to why even if they don't use youtube
why they should just go and subscribe
for you okay just so that it's we have
the subscriber so if you're listening as
a podcast then you know that we put our
heart and soul we do an hour a day five
days a week most weeks and the show is
completely free so we don't really ask
anything of you we don't ask you to pay
for the show we love to do it for free
so i'm actually demanding now i will
make this show
25 000 a day unless everyone listening
goes to podcasts goes to youtube.com
search the morning toast and subscribe
you say claudia i don't have a youtube
account yet you do actually every person
on the planet with the gmail has a
youtube account so like please just
subscribe i really
want to get like 100k and also like now
that you moved like
they have to give us two plaques if and
when we hit it right because you need
one in here and i need one in new york
yeah okay i just want to make sure like
youtube is listening yeah
okay i don't think they are but we'll
we'll deal with that or we could we
could have like a replica made once we
get the first one i'll take the replica
because i know how important the
original is to you that's so nice i just
want you to know like if everyone who's
listening as a podcast like in the first
20 minutes this goes up just went and
subscribed like we would be at our goal
and it could be you you could be the one
to make the difference
you
so let's see i want to see where we are
right now in subscribers
and see how many people oh my god amber
alert damn that's sad okay uh here we go
oh my god you got a two yeah
okay i have
i have the number okay screenshot it
we're watching we're watching you please
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasts can be found that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio iot
radio cast blocks all the places where
we listen to podcast find us the morning
trust leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are have
an incred thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow for the final show of the week
on
friday friday gotta get down on friday
goodbye goodbye goodbye bruno goodbye
theo your mommy loves you